alors si ray la semaine dernière je sais
pas si vous vous rappelez mai et s'était
passé ça et oui oui je sais ça fait
bientôt là oui c'est une image arrêtée
quai c'est bien davantage faire tu
mesures à mettre tout sur ses
passe-temps passe-muraille apas mezouza
[Rires]
on a eu un fou rire et les
téléspectateurs et les chroniqueurs
m'ont demandé pourquoi on avait eu ce
fou rire et comme je vais vous savez
syrie le fil indique agir je dois tout
dénoncer tout dire aux téléspectateurs
bien sûr on recevait jean veil jean veil
un très grand avocat très sérieux très
sympa mais on va pas se mentir cette
personne n'a pas dû rigoler depuis 1958
avec une paire sympathie voilà de quoi
c'est parce que toi tu iras mais alors
dit à des a priori mais non mais vous
rappelez pas du fou rire qu'on a eue
alors pourquoi pas mais ils étaient
personnels castagne était riche et très
très régulier thomas castaldi vive et
péter d'oseille
on va vers ton lancement d'un oui je
reste surpris à regarder bien la fin du
magnéto comment cyril arrivent à se
sortir du fou rire il ya que lui qu'un
matin matin c'est ça c'est ça que j'aime
oui
[Rires]
tu veux ou tu es revenu lâche toi tu es
là matière à sa maintenance à 8 mp le
court je rappelle qu à la voir non mais
moi aussi et on m'a demandé de regarder
parce que april elle veut rigoler mais
si je ne sais pas si c'est moi ou pas et
vous voulez pas regarder je veux pas le
regarder
non je l'adoré une excellente c'est
qu'il est hyper sympathique ont mis les
frais après c'est vrai qu'on regarde
arrive dans un endroit où tu vois qu'un
mec qui dit tu l'as vu qu'il dit qu on
est quand même chez nous dans ses
délires à gauche et ses portes il va
dire oh mais la voir mais l'avoir gardé
bien puisqu'il ya regardez bien la miss
[Rires]
le pot balle de 5-2 mais tous n'ont pas
obéi à montmagny non mais il était très
sympa très sympathique franchement ça
soit frais voilà ta gueule alors ça va
vous sinon très bien fait du bien de
rigoler un peu je sais rien il flatte
archaïque et si l'atp stade on continue
avec une séquence star du paf que tous
les loups dans la bergerie de france et
le glaciologue clame voici tout de suite
50 secondes inside to pay pay c'est fort
quand tu fais un salut à tous et
bienvenue dans cinq ans selon inside de
pmp et on commence tout de suite avec
baba qui visiblement connaît très bien
les règles de top chef qui monte
allez ouverture le cul mais c'est ainsi
il n'y a pas qu isabelle morini bosc à
des problèmes d'audition dans tpm peut
on pas vrai que les babas président 2022
en tout cas il a déjà son programme
pourquoi ya un président à président
mais c'est ça sans rigoler sinon on
n'avance pas c'est c'est toujours
prendre une décision une décision une
décision de l'argent et qu'on bat jean
marie mai des démissions il peut
toujours compter sur guillaume genton
sur la même antenne
je suis inquiet pour sa carrière je sais
c'est henri capron tu peux passer de
prime sur tf1
et puis quand on vous dit que casta
sakho stone le loup qu'est ce qui a
changé en 20 ans balata gueule toi et
quand ma bar en bar le beau le grand
bref le meilleur d'entre nous sacha ça
donne ça c'est d'être avec no mercy
mercy
on est dans la com et se nomme tony en
tout cas of benjamin segonne dongle
bouffonne et bouffonne mais ces tapis
dans l'ombre
stéphane ce prix un énorme vent dans
chacune merci twitter
cette année
est plus faible qu'à son boomerang il
peut vous revenir très vite dans la
tronche sécuritaire ne l'arrêté
[Musique]
cette semaine donc termine pas par amo
fait par un conseil ce n'est pas un
conseil à vos journées à vous donner je
vous dis avant tout faites vous vacciner
contre la connerie c'est vrai j'avance
pas toujours le mot gentil gabon is a
renchéri et non pas avec moi mon coeur
ah oui c'est moi je t'aime un thé
musique et rtl faut que tu passes les
deux parce que c'est encore une question
d'argent
au niveau de l'envié on sait très bien
que tu es mieux ici à ses deux salles
deux ambiances
oui c'est vrai me dit rien c'est ce que
tu penses chercher les endroits
s'inquiètent pas en lisant brasserie du
travail à ce patron c'est un amour à
j'aime beaucoup
ouais je sais là bas lui aussi des
mairies sytème épuisé toutes façons un
21 ans de série 26 ans de airtel 11 ans
le cd 11 ans de ses limites en compte ce
que ça leur coûterait 6 et débarrassé de
son arme et ils ont raison tata
indéboulonnable au tout cas chez moi
j'aime compte hélas ma chérie fais
pareil et gilles été très bons
aujourd'hui par mercy est ouvert les
compliments à tous je trouves tu fais
une saison incroyable
merci moussa tine d'être là réellement
intelligente à 16 ans city incroyable ce
que tu fais et toi guillaume elmont bien
habillés et c'est à dire
vous savez que vous avez glop
c'est à dire pour ceux qui ne la fasse
payer pour ce que ça va vous étiez là
maintenant vous êtes là vous êtes de
plus en plus beau que tu continues à on
est sur les compliments vous êtes de
plus en plus sexy
vous êtes de plus en plus charmant que
tu vas me [ __ ] dans la gueule la
preuve la quasi-totalité des invités
invités et es ont succombé à votre
charme cyril cette semaine c'est quoi je
vous faire un aveu moi aussi je suis à
d'autres succombé à oui nous fait
craquer comme une biscotte cyril là bas
je suis con parce que tu vas prendre la
confiture de relaxe alors elle et elle
est jolie elle est jolie et elle et elle
est intelligente jolie seriez belle
porte parole de la république en marche
le gars est la porte vers la parole de
son enfant et de voilà de son parti
comment ça ma mode ça va être quoi sert
il battre
[Applaudissements]
dans la salle et toi tu es blessé tu
laisse pousser un tollé à gauche c'est
pas mal un des miens moncton sympathie
petit récap et notre ministre sera avec
nous en place juste après c'est parti
mabrouk agnès à la tenue en suspens mais
agnès il est chaud l'osi conquis que de
plus en plus belles cités tous merci
beaucoup à l'espagne est fier d'avoir
avec nous et le maroc
le blazer merci anniversaire de super
france le groupe de plus
[Musique]
cécile est avec no mercy cécile d'être
là et cécile qui est magnifique on peut
pas croire que vous rester célibataire
votre tête disait oui votre corps disait
non voilà
allez moi vous êtes chef des nouveaux en
fait cette amoureuse merci bien sûr
[Musique]
mais on est
[Applaudissements]
c'est le problème les montages vous fait
dire ça et ça ça me dégoûte et je
voudrais de rennes devant les tribunaux
je vous le dis j'ai un bon avocat qui la
porte parole je trouve qu'il ya quelque
chose quand même
alors si on n'a pas le droit d'avoir des
amis
je connais un petit peu moi j'en connais
un petit peu aussi je sais très bien que
quand vous allez rester très vite chez
vous c'est une copine valérie pécresse
et l'odeur dégagée par toi la fusée
taille avec nous j'adore tes yeux à
lhassa c'est le mec c'est quoi ta et pis
c'est le mec tu qu'ils feraient pas
détails que l'on classe toujours d'arc à
rien et un truc de sport à faire il est
là surtout maintenant et oui c'est
vraiment le poids idéal
je sais pas en tout cas je suis toujours
positif c'est ça la change je vois la
vie toujours d'une façon avec d'énergie
avec des projets j'ai tellement de
projets dans celle que j'avais envie de
refaire en records mais bon on pense qu
défaire des années je les ai jamais vus
en race rare n y pas de ça voilà
toujours un peu le sourire toujours
encaissé j'ai même quand j'étais sur mon
lit d'hôpital j'ai même écrit un petit
proverbe qui est qui et où m quand vous
êtes dans le noir au fond du gouffre
trouvez vous un rêve quel qu'il soit
suivi le aveuglément il vous le ramènera
à la lumière je bosse
[Applaudissements]
j'avais même un scénario quand vous êtes
dans le noir au fond du court moi
j'avais mis juste allumer la lumière
mais lui il était pas mais tu vois tu va
plus loin m
coupe oui c'est l'ailé avant de lancer
le prochain magnéto j'ai une surprise
pour vous mais ça suffit les surprises
sociaux depuis tout à l'heure je manque
encore la snel surprise mais je sais pas
si vous l'avez vu en coulisses c'est
quoi mon cul je lance le challenge dans
ton cul grâce à sa chaleur
si vous faites un dans ton cul à votre
patron que ce soit au téléphone c'est
très beau que ce soit en télétravail
que ce soit dans le bureau voilà vous
c'est franchement ses joues le dis vous
me les envoyer gelé passera l'antenne et
le meilleur de la semaine
je lui offre 1000 boul la semaine je le
lance tout de suite je lance tout de
suite ce défi le hashtag du dans ton cul
à 13,3 en patron le dans ton cul à son
boss d'accord voilà parce que tu suives
de ou vers le bas les gens à gagner les
villes d'indemnités
ça prendrait donc donc cette vanne oui
le niveau de cette vanne que vous vous
allez génial à la maison et bien les
deux petit chenapan du paf benjamin
castaldi cyril hanouna ont passé leur
semaine à faire ça mais pas con
chroniqueur aux invités aussi et même
parfois même à des gars très sérieux
regardez
[Musique]
à quoi
c'est une bonne nouvelle danse il est où
là mais où là est-ce que vous avez revu
oui nico tu étais au paddock soutient
nos maris tête avec qui tu la joues pas
mon cul
[Musique]
et quand même sous les 1 soit tu
sauveras de voir ce que voulaient les
revues mon q bat exclusive à t'excuser
haut
[Musique]
mais bien 50 qui désirent je pense que
c'est le tube de l'histoire est ce qu'on
peut me l'isoler j'aimerais regardez
bien cette année et la force de castaldi
derrière et est à la tête de dix bijoux
je pense que ce connard voir ces photos
c'est magnifique c'est énorme
c'est les boules perdu mon cul
[Rires]
ce que je voulais vous dire c'est ma
garonne qui m'a dit ça là bas il ya
toujours un
elle me dit que ma soeur j'ai une grande
soeur de mi-temps monde est née une
fille formidable et elle me dit que ma
soeur était amoureuse de l'homme et
chroniqueur nom à l'époque vous rendez
compte ou pas est vrai et j'ai vu je
voulais partager avec vous parce que
j'ai eu à dire quand j'ai pris ça dans
la gueule ça a fait bim bam boum
non mais t'as tes dents mais voilà bien
ce chroniqueur ce chroniqueur c'est pas
bon parce que si ma soeur est amoureuse
de toi ça serait pas une cougar frères
1,16 c'est mon premier pas j'aurais bien
manger en tout cas pourquoi que tu crois
pas ce que je dois faire de bons petits
plats
mais alors qu'est-ce que ça que ces
préjugés
mais du sexy je crois que vous êtes
d'obédience à peu tunisie oui tu vas été
traitées chômage ou alors c'est qui ce
que ce chroniqueur il est là ce soir à
bernabéu
ma soeur est amoureuse de deux
chroniqueurs en fait ça me fait peur
mais là elle qui fait bernard montiel
j'te jure c'est vrai elle vous avez un
jour à cannes au festival c'est gentil
elle avait pris une photo avec vous elle
ma vie dit il est super sympa mais il
faut qu'il mette du déodorant
alors elle vous a t elle
l éthique mais celui qui allait me diouf
s'était castany ouais ah oui ou non elle
était non mais vraiment bien à quelle
époque
à l'époque love story oui à tout ça mais
vraiment j'aurais trouvé vous étiez le
plus beau du monde
mais ces essais ce jour là haut je vous
jure que c'est vrai j'aime raconter
l'histoire
on est comme ça avec ma mère j'étais
tout petit et ont regardé castaldi qui
regardaient love story ont regardé love
story et j'étais que ma soeur et ma
soeur on est comme ça avec ma mère mon
père et toute la famille ont regardé le
show room était fan et là ma soeur dit
j'ai une révélation qu'est ce qu'il est
beau castaldi et c'est là que mon père
qui est médecin appeler son copain
ophtalmo si la reprise qui l'a prise en
urgence
[Rires]
hansel il va nous faire une marie de la
petite maison dans la prairie
franchement oui je te dis non mélanome
elle était amoureuse de vous narrer
bongo elle vous adore toujours c'est
vrai et c'est vraiment dur et moi à
chaque fois que tu dis franchement tu as
raison c'est un super mec et but et
s'est déjà marié cinq fois cinq ou six
fois et j'ai déjà compter ma soeur c'est
un package c'est pour amener ces canaux
fois n'est qu'aux et on s'énerve très
beau frère ah c'est bon ça serait drôle
franchement mérité sympa samassa
m'aurait arrangé à cause de l'argent
après vraiment que je donnais d'argent
mon beau-frère ses parts avant de
repartir
eh bien figurez vous que j'ai une
question à vous poser est ce que vous en
avez quelque chose à faire quand les
gens vous partirez bien sûr alors j'ai
l'impression que j'en avais rien à
carrer quoi les chroniqueurs les invités
etc
regardez bien le magic au qui va devenir
ce que tu as toi oui un acte suscite eu
d'un méchant avec le coin le succès
le succès fut enfin le succès les
suceurs c'est là le succès c'est vous
c'est le dessin animé albator découvrez
le nouveau dessin animé avec cyril
hanouna guest star albatar atteint que
tu as bossé pour ça nous apprennent
store
le bâtard des médias
grâce à vianney l'accord aussi fanta les
yeux revolver
[Rires]
benjamin je te le dis en toute amitié
j'aime pas ta gueule une démonstration
était assis à ma place il est sérieux à
faire qu'un truc que cherche et f1
depuis très longtemps c'est quoi mika
ouais comme ils sont allés en polynésie
qu'ils ont tourné pendant la pandémie
qu'elle était moche ci l'aurait pas fait
d'essais ils sont tellement dur sens
qu'elles n'ont pas même pas bien sûr
c'est un truc qui est tourné de façon un
petit peu de télé réalité donc on veut
savoir ce qui se passe vraiment dans
l'aventuré oui non oui justement
réfléchi à la question de savoir qu'est
ce que je fais quand je sais pas eh ben
je ferme ma gueule
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
oui merci
sacha elle bat tu vas où il avait battu
sais pas comment je vais manger la
chukka salue pas trop quand même
la vertu pourra plus prendre du 10 ans